(laughs)
- Hey, hey, hey,
it's us, Girls5eva.
(all)
- Girls5eva!
- We're gonna be famous
for fun-hundred years,
'cause it's like five
more than a hundred.
- All we know is we're
gonna make this count!
♪ Gonna be famous 5eva ♪
♪ 'Cause 4eva's too short ♪
♪ Gonna be famous 3gether ♪
♪ 'Cause that's 1
more than 2gether ♪
♪ People starin' at us
thinkin' we are badass ♪
♪ Watchin' as we wave goodbye
our stomachs are the flattest ♪
♪ Riding in our Lexus
life rarely affects us ♪
♪ Drinkin' Veuve
Clicquot champagne ♪
♪ and texting all our exes ♪
♪ Playing with our
brand new flip phones ♪
♪ Talkin' with our friends
Talkin' with our friends ♪
♪ See the new ink
on our hip bones ♪
♪ that's how
our story begins ♪
♪ Gonna be famous 5eva ♪
♪ 'Cause 4eva's too short
It's too short ♪
♪ Gonna be famous
3gether ♪
♪ 'Cause that's 1
more than 2gether ♪
♪ Riding with my ladies
we now got a Mercedes ♪
♪ Makin' rhymes
and tellin' jokes ♪
♪ like regular
Wayne Bradys ♪
♪ Shoe shoppin'
with my sisters ♪
♪ the Loubitons
left blisters ♪
♪ That sales girl
was really cute ♪
♪ I accidentally
kissed her ♪
♪ We used to play pretend
on the playground ♪
♪ Some girls will call us dumb
Some girls will call us dumb ♪
♪ But all those haters
now will bow down ♪
♪ When they see
what we've become ♪
♪ Gonna be famous 5eva ♪
♪ 'Cause 4eva's too short
Oh no no ♪
♪ Gonna be famous
3gether ♪
♪ 'Cause that's 1 more
than 2gether ♪
♪ We won the prize 2gether
our fame starts 3day ♪
♪ And it won't
stop 4morrow ♪
♪ We're Girls5eva,
can we get a high 6? ♪
♪ We working 24/7
to keep you in 8th heaven ♪
♪ Checkin' out the hotties
with their sexy bodies ♪
♪ still drinking
Veuve Clicquot Champagne ♪
♪ we all got Maseratis ♪
♪ Chillin' at Mercado
sharin' a gelato ♪
♪ We'll all be birds
and fly away ♪
♪ just like
Nelly Furtado ♪
♪ We looked at all the numbers
and placed our bet ♪
♪ Our future
adds up to this ♪
♪ the best things
haven't happened yet ♪
♪ We're gonna be famous 5eva ♪
♪ 'Cause 4eva's too short
It's too short ♪
♪ Gonna be famous
3gether ♪
♪ 'Cause that's 1 more
than 2gether ♪
♪ Gonna be famous 5ever
'Cause 4eva's too short ♪
♪ So what are you
waiting 5? ♪
♪ Girls5eva ♪